hello and welcome to fat man on Batman
all news all mark edition mighty keV is
up in Vancouver making Supergirl fly so
come on back we're gonna talk about some
things that happened this week and maybe
last week and maybe into next week on
this all news edition the fat man on
Batman
hey guys so I'm by myself in the fat
cave this time and our awesome
TCL monitor appointed phat cave that's
all pretty and spiffy and has all kinds
of light coming from everywhere against
me bathing me in the glow of my own face
which is a weird thing to say the least
but yeah like I said Kevin Vancouver
directing his first episode of Supergirl
so he will come back at some point and
give us all kinds of secrets and needy
and gritty and all of the nooks and
crannies that happen in National City
but for now it's just me it just me and
you
we're gonna have a nice quiet time give
that man a single what I'm calling my
own singles [ __ ] yes back to the 2-shot
just for me there's nobody else in the
to shop I'm just gonna do that because
it's kind of fun alright so let's get to
some news right first bit of news sad
bit of news Steve Dylan artist who
worked for both Marvel and DC most
notably on the preacher series that he
did with Garth Ennis and the Punisher
that he also did with Garth Ennis and
was also working on a new book from
Marvel a new Punisher book with Becky
Cloonan has passed away the the
circumstances still seem to be somewhat
mysterious there's been no official
cause of death other than it was
relatively sudden and he was relatively
younger but he was like 56 or so but um
but the preacher especially is a
defining series in both comics at large
and for me personally like there was it
was the first time that I saw comics as
in love with America as I am and it's
and it's funny that only only a
foreigner can be that kind of in love
with America can see the romance for
what it is I mean if you're born here
like I was then America is just like I
went back to New York I'm from New York
recently I went back and and having
lived in Los Angeles for like five years
going back here was the first time I
experienced it like a tourist like I did
all of those things that you do if
you're new like you go to the Statue of
Liberty you go to the Empire State
Building you go see some museums when
you grow up there you take it all for
granted but when you visit someplace
you're entranced by it weaves this spell
on you and you get the romance of a play
when you're a visitor that you don't get
if you're resident and that to me is
what preacher was to the American West
to the American Road story was this this
love letter to it yes with vampires and
butter statute [ __ ] old millionaires
and thieves and gods and saints of
killers and all that stuff but it was
really a sort of sonnet to the things
that America could be and the potential
of America to move past some of its
earlier sins and and become a place
that's that's worth fighting for and
that book would not have been the same
without Steve Dillon I mean Garth
anissa's words are beautiful and great
and fantastic but I mean comics is a
collaborative medium and without the art
the words don't it lifts each other up
it's it's a symbiotic relationship one
cannot exist without the other
and Steve Dillon was the artist for that
book and and his his passing has left a
hole in comics that will not easily be
filled so rest in peace Steve Dillon
Godspeed and we'll just keep reading
we'll go back you left a lot of good
stuff for all of us so yes under
somewhat happier note there was a
there's a casting this past week that
felt as if it belonged it was destined
to happen give me a single lando
calrissian was cast for the young Han
Solo movie the ads yet untitled young
han solo movie and who did they cast
take another single over here no the
cameras off over here fog I screwed up
see that's why I shouldn't call my own
shots without Kevin here it's a waste of
time Donald Glover got cast as young han
Solo haha there would be funny right no
Donna got cast as young Lando Calrissian
in the young Han Solo movie my dream of
Dreams and it was a dream that started
you know back when I first saw Lando
Calrissian Swan his way into Empire
Strikes Back and when you get the
backstory of exactly how Han Solo got
ahold of the Millennium Falcon he lost
it he wanted in a card game from Lando I
want to see that card game I want to see
the smugglers run I want to see the life
of these two young band
in the middle of the galaxy doing awful
awful [ __ ] to people who probably didn't
deserve it I want to see it be fun you
know like III as much as I love what
rogue one feels like it's going to be
this sort of little pocket in the middle
of Star Wars where it's a war movie I
want to see a heist movie show me a
heist movie in the Star Wars universe
and I will show you my money I will be
there first day online not online I'll
buy my tickets early because I'm not a
Philistine but yes I'm there you you get
my money Donald Glover who once upon a
time was was bandied about by the
internet for black spider-man who would
eventually give birth to Miles Morales
because Brian Michael Bendis read about
Donald Glover as pseudo like passive
campaign to be spider-man and said well
why couldn't spider-man be somebody of
color why couldn't spider-man be
somebody you know who might be half
black and half Latino why does
spider-man half be white guy was the
question that Brian Bendis asked and the
answer was he doesn't and so that sort
of got Donald Glover in the bit of the
geeks fear and that seems to have been
at least part of the foundation for this
decision from Chris Miller and Phil Lord
who are writing and directing the new
young Han Solo movie has yet untitled
young Han Solo movie which i think is
due out in 2018 but yes Donald Glover
[ __ ] yes done I can't imagine anybody
else I would want to see do that more
than him remember I know I misspoke he's
not playing young Han Solo although I
would also watch that so yeah Alden
Ehrenreich is playing on house although
so that's taken care of but now we got
that we got this I now wouldn't want to
know who's gonna be young Chewbacca
so tell me Internet who should be young
Chewbacca I mean Paul Giamatti behind
the mask would not be weird right
like I would watch that maybe some
wrestler perhaps just get the rock like
it's Disney money they can get the rock
to play young young young Chewbacca I
mean even ease his face we know he's in
there I'm sad eyebrow arrays they can do
that [ __ ] with animatronics like the
universe let's make
happened to we had a couple trailers
drop to two very very noteworthy
trailers drop in the last fortnight we
had Logan the the old man Logan as we we
and the fat cave like to call it the
version of Mark Millar and Stephen Evans
book which posits a Logan at the end of
his days
the thing that comics never gets to do
you know comics are entirely and always
and it's part of the reason where we
love them where they are the second act
of the story the origin story which is
either one issue or a miniseries or
whatever gives you the beginning the
first act here's how we got to be the
way he is we get nothing but second act
which is running jumping doing stuff we
never get the third act which is the
ending you know occasionally like Dark
Knight Returns is the ending of what
that Batman story would be but because
comics has to exist always in perpetuity
there has to be in next comic there is
never a last comic that way we never get
an ending except occasionally these
comic book companies will decide to give
us one an old man Logan was that thing
so Logan also feels a bit like that
thing it's it's the end of days for for
our man played by Hugh Jackman who looks
like he's finally not had to work out
for 17 hours a day and eat nothing but
boiled chickens and steamed rice for
weeks on end to get that ridiculously
cut figure like it's it's him when the
healing factor sort of lets slip a
little bit it's him it's him at the end
of his run I looked at that teaser
trailer and I was like it's unforgiving
with claws that is all I [ __ ] need if
you tell me that's what I'm gonna get
then I again I'm there first night not
online because I'm not a [ __ ] buy my
tickets early but the good seats I'm
buying my tickets early not gonna be
online now I'm buying them early logan
trailer number one totally badass
number two guardians of the galaxy vol 2
teaser dropped and it's just so like
it's a warm to get back in the world
with those guys I mean it's just even
like the faint echoes of of you know who
got Chaka ooga chokka even the little
[ __ ] baby group that you see where
the little tiny starlet or a jacket it's
just it is a warm hug from
so we haven't seen in quite a while and
I'm totally on board
I it's funny I was at the doctor strange
premiere which we will not talk about
this episode because we're gonna wait
for Kevin for that but it was at the
premiere and I ran into a guy can't give
me his name but he had some inside dope
into what was happening in the in the
post production a movie like it's all
shot it's on the can they're starting to
edit now and it's like you know what Dad
is tip of the iceberg like it is it is
not at all the we got the best parts of
that movie and put it in that teaser he
said there's a boatload of more awesome
so awesome more yes thank you here's the
thing I did well I knew Kevin was gonna
be gone for about ten days and I figured
that I would start to dip my toes back
into things that I have forsaken
personally for me that was agents of
shield which I pretty much gave up on in
the beginning of the third season but
when I heard that that Robby ray is his
Ghost Rider was was going to be brought
onto the show Mike all right I need to
watch that so I caught up with the last
few episodes of the third season that
gave us you know desi turning it to
quake and whatever happened with hive
which is now a villains name that's in
nine different shows because I guess
it's cool it's like the company or
whatever but and I watched the first
four of this season and you know what
I'm kind of back on board I mean I think
that what they needed to do on that show
that they hadn't done a chance to do was
both reset a little bit hold some of the
old storylines and just snip them off
and sever them all like agent ward
apparently not on the show anymore
and you know what fine with that I was
kind of done with a like turncoat
betrayal insidious emotions and whatever
I'm here for the pulp I'm here for a
[ __ ] charge if it gets on fire and
turns into a smoking hellbeast
conveyance that's why I show up I show
up because I want to see you know
sucking in humans hauling off on each
other I want to see big dudes with big
guns shooting each other and flaming
links of chain that's whack show up for
Marvel's agents of shield and that's
what I got you know so I'm kind of back
on board I didn't expect that to happen
but I'm
I'm a little bit back on board the other
thing I caught up with a little bit
given that the namesake of our show is
fat man I'm Batman I figured yes yes
people on the internet you're right I
should probably give Gotham another try
so I watched the first episode of Gotham
season where are we four five three I
can't I can't keep track
mad city because they're giving each
season it's a little name mad city gets
to me the thing I recall is I saw the
first episode of Mad City
fish Mooney seems to be back I don't
know why I think Jim Gordon's
ex-girlfriend fiance is now running a
nightclub that used to be owned by fish
Mooney with her lesbian lover who was
the sister girlfriend of galavant
or whatever his name was and if I don't
remember it's uh I cannot say that I'm
on board with this just yet it seems as
if they're kind of going for broke a
little bit which I always respect I
respected my show realizes okay [ __ ] it
I guess we can just go for it we need to
do whatever you want to do whenever like
a stegasaurus dude fine Jim Gordon's
done with bounty hunter okay why not
lesbian love affairs absolutely we
should have that from the beginning I
feel like this is a show that if not in
it's as as they sometimes call it in
behavioral psychology extinction bursts
it is the-- it is that when you have a
behavior that is out of control and what
you want to do is get rid of that
behavior this is the last flare of that
behavior that is the like you know if
you bite your nails you don't want to do
and you're trying to get rid of it but
right before that behavior goes away you
buy all your [ __ ] nails off
extinction burst I feel as if like I
don't know if if gotham mad city will
then evolve into Gotham whatever other
City it's gonna be but if it doesn't I
kind of respect that they're just
playing all their cards in the table at
this point
that is that's a bold move and bold
strokes and I'm all about that
it still has yet to dig in to me the way
I need a show to at this point in its
fourth season but I gave it a go you
know I can't I decided that I know I
owed it to the show to revisit gear in
that you know especially since my my
entree on
to the fat man I'm Batman as a regular
guest sidekick host person was to do
Gotham episode by episode synopses
commentaries we let that slide for a bit
probably about 24 episodes a year and a
half worth so yeah I decided to check
back in verdict is still out here's
another bit of news that is somewhat
troubling in the geekus fear Deadpool 2
is absolutely gonna happen they are
making this movie they are now casting
there's apparently six actresses who
name still under wraps who are testing
for Domino which would be the female
lead in Deadpool 2 but director Tim
Miller that kid that we've been talking
about for like six months has left the
movie over creative differences which is
always this weird like catch-all phrase
for everybody hated each other or the
script is a piece of [ __ ] or the
producer had no idea what he was doing
or the director was often a bender or
any number of things that can go wrong
in the development of a movie all get
bundled up into creative differences the
same way that whenever like somebody
cancels a tour because of exhaustion
it's never exhausting nobody's tired and
gives up 40 million dollars it's not
exhaustion and apparently the source of
the creative differences was a conflict
between Tim Miller our boy founder blurr
Studios who by all accounts leaked the
test footage of Deadpool and coerced Fox
into green-lighting it and kept the
tenor in the tone and the humor and and
and helped steer that ship into
delivering a movie that felt that it was
what it should have been it wasn't
reaching too far it wasn't trying to
embrace too much he was trying to be the
best version of Deadpool that it could
be and that sort of thing always ends up
falling to the director for good for bad
for for better or worse that is the
person for whom that responsibility
falls but one could also say that a
great deal of the reason why I did pole
worked was because of Ryan Reynolds who
you know brought that character to life
and absolutely understood the humor and
absolutely went for it like that's a guy
who who pushed the boundaries of what
traditional like male movie stars in a
superhero movie
would do would be willing to do there's
a pegging scene in Dead Pool that does
not happen in your average Marvel movie
and I do believe that part of that is
because Ryan Reynolds was willing to go
there because again this movie was about
giving you the version of the character
that is the most attuned and the most in
sync with what we know as comic-book
readers but there are some split between
those two guys there was some
dissolution of unity there was some
fracturing of the worlds and creative
differences and so Tim Miller is now
left the project they're still gonna
make it
they're absolutely gonna make this movie
because when the first Deadpool makes
almost 800 million dollars worldwide you
make a sequel you just do that is the
way Hollywood works that is the way that
math comes together there's going to be
a sequel somebody will direct it we
don't know who that is just yet I mean
I'm sure there are ideas of people who
could do that I mean and the right would
be great at it I feel like Ryan Johnson
if you want it to be super funny could
be great at that James Gunn could
absolutely deliver a good Deadpool but
I'm pretty sure he's busy in that other
world there's a guy who's usually next
to me on this here dance who could
probably take a swing at Deadpool and
make it a grand old time but that is
they we are just speculating at this
point there is no nobody has made a
decision what if they have haven't told
us so yeah that's a somewhat sad news
only because we wanted that band to get
back together and really nobody wants a
replacement ring though unless they do
unless they did replace ring though we
don't know [ __ ] life model decoy
could have been why not I mean all he's
doing is drumming and the last bit of
news was in kind of in the spirit of
checking back in on shows that I have
given up on in the past Walking Dead I
stopped watching that show about halfway
through the govenor season not because I
didn't like it like I was right or die
on that show from the beginning even
through the weird-ass lazy detour on to
the farm but I moved like I relocated I
moved from New Jersey to Los Angeles and
in that process like I didn't have a DVR
I didn't have
any TV I didn't have all of those things
you need to have to stay up-to-date on
TV show and it just it's severed the
link in the chain it is it broke the
streak and once that streak broke I was
never that motivated to dig back into it
and I just kept seeing things happen I
terminus Wu terminus what oh hey negan's
coming well okay maybe maybe I'll tune
in and see where this whole negan
business is about and it's about
something I just don't know what that is
I watched the premiere and I'll say that
like I know the internet is divided on
this and that it is true to the comics
and then yes they killed a person who
probably should have been dead long
before and they killed another person
who some people care for some people
don't I didn't because I never saw him
on the show when I stopped watching so
no they killed it dude I've never seen
before
pity I do feel like it was a well-done
episode like dramatically speaking like
I think it holds together I think the
the the parsing out the the careful slow
reveal of who got a chance to kiss them
steel with their foreheads repeatedly
who those people would be I will say
that there's a there's an element of
both sadism on the show's part and
masochism on the the viewers part that
this is kind of what they want from
their TV I don't know like when I watch
a TV show that I expect to have some
sort of conclusion I don't necessarily
want that conclusion to be or dear God
that was it oh dear God everybody's dead
or they just will live in misery until
their days are over and goodnight
like and I get that that's part of what
Walking Dead is about I get that that
you know as it says in a very large
double page splash we are The Walking
Dead like it's a show about the humans
who have to live in this place and in
this time and in these conditions
well I'm Man Alive that's a grim [ __ ]
future to have to devote what is looking
like we'll be nine years of one's life
to get to the end of and there will be
no resolution to that show beyond they
just stop making it you know like say
what you want to say about lost and I've
in print and in many places before you
know it's a show that had overstate its
welcome by about a year but it had a
mending now whether you felt that ending
was satisfactory or not whether you felt
that the sort of kumbaya in a church
everybody hugs and goes off to heaven
gave you the emotional story resolution
you were looking for after that many
hours of loss that you devoted to it
open for debate
you know you will like it how you liked
it I liked the emotionality of it I
liked that it it it gave me the sense
that those characters had finished their
journey even if the sort of logical part
of my brain was not happy with how they
achieved and arrived at their the the
conclusion of their journey but at least
there was an ending at least there was a
you know hey Battlestar whatever
Starbuck might be an alien or an angel
we can't tell we don't know but you know
what it ended it it ended in a way that
sort of it wrapped up the show and a bow
that made sense in its own internal
logic I don't know what the ending of
his walking of Walking Dead is beyond Oh
everybody's dead I guess you know there
is going to be a no cure I don't know
why suddenly sound like Mario that is
what me I'm no cure but or John big boot
a there's no cure to the to the disease
that gave I mean they they sealed off
that storyline the end of the first
season where they went to the CDC and it
all blows up so nobody's finding a cure
to this this is now just the way things
are
so where do they go to that provide some
semblance of respite some kind of
retreat I don't know they don't seem to
get any rush to get there are they going
to kill every other human that's alive
who knows are they all going to die
who knows none of those things seem to
be the man alive I'm glad I devoted 10
years to this show and I don't know what
the ending is the comic seems to not
flag at all
I'm sure Kirkman might have thought of
some potential ending of what the show
could be that would give us as the
viewer some sense that the time we have
invested had yielded a reward but it's a
grim trail guys like it's it's it's a
little bit nihilistic and it
taking a weird glee in that sense of
annihilation but that is just me that is
my take on it as a person who has not
watched in a couple of years and to be
confronted with that made me think that
perhaps I was at least for my own sanity
kind of okay leaving leaving in the
walking dead behind and walking on
beyond the walking dead but you know who
might have thoughts on this differently
our man Kevin Smith give me a single
Kevin he's in Vancouver but he's
watching back to the 2-shot see I can do
this okay I [ __ ] up once I know
there's no camera there I [ __ ] that up
but we're back okay we can make this
happen I will be back with you a little
bit later I'm gonna talk about horror
and I'm gonna have a special guest yes I
will
it's gonna be awesome I'll see you guys
soon WW calm slash Kevin Smith on the
youtubes and SModcast comm TCL gave us
some monitors made it so happy all right
hey man it's me Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder